[Music]
john i know this was important uh you
called me you asked if you could come
out here and talk about this what is
your problem with the nba well as a fan
of the nba as we all were um they kind
of left us in the dark for two months
they took something away from us they
left us with a certain emptiness a
certain sadness
and the nba of course has promised to
make it up to us but what i decided to
do because i don't know if i believe
that with two lockouts in the past 14
years so what i decided to do was to go
out and find a league that cares about
its players and respects its fans like
this audience as well the greatest
audience i've ever seen
the greatest
so did you find you
you went out and looking uh for a league
that would respect the fans did you find
such a league i did find a league here
watch this
mustangs
what's your name micah
micah micah and how do you spell micah
m-i-c-a-a oh with letters yeah oh gotcha
how much were the tickets to today's
game zero dollars you don't have to pay
a cent to watch the game nothing that's
great because then you don't have to go
into your piggy bank right i know so
you're here to watch basketball as well
oh
well
mostly
yes but i'm interested in other like
like the black holes and space and
underwater
stuff like that how much do you get paid
to play in the league
there are dollars
i didn't get paid
why do you do it then
for fun
yeah
are you a communist
[Music]
do you ever fear that this league will
be locked out much like the nba was
have you ever been locked out of the
house
oh yeah what's that feel like
it feels like my little brother's trying
to keep me out of the house
and you would never let the fans of this
league have that feeling would you nope
no because you
play
and
i don't know what you're looking for
with
my team and
uh 12
exactly
have you guys ever met before this
season the two of you
yeah we're twins
you're
and my voice is different your voice is
different than his will say something
yeah it does sound a little bit
different you're right about that
why do you think the commissioner of
this league and the players have such a
harmonious relationship
because they're small and they don't
know what they're doing how tall are you
i'm about four foot
three or three is that right
i guess so yeah yeah all right are you
guys nervous that one of the players on
the other team is four foot three
yes
oh terrify me how great is it that this
basketball league has never locked out
its players
what do you mean by lockdown i mean
they've never restricted any players
restricted in a sense yes they've never
they've always been able to come to an
agreement with their players so that the
game can go on and the fans can watch it
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's fun to watch basketball i mean it's
almost as fun as playing video games
what are you guys gonna do now we're
going to play date with gregory you're
going to have a play date with gregory
that sounds like fun so after a
wonderful day of basketball you go and
have a play date
yup and maybe a sleepover right are you
guys going to call your girlfriends and
tell them that you won
i don't even have one you don't have a
girlfriend do you have a girlfriend
we're nine
so you don't make any money playing in
the league nope well then you'd probably
be pretty open to a sneaker sponsorship
um i don't know if you'd be interested
but conan o'brien
has put on his own shoe this is the air
coco it has of course the red hair
follicle soul and the double windsor tie
tongue
now
conan o'brien has come out with a new
basketball sneaker and i'm going to show
it to you right now
[Applause]
do you like that yeah well we'll pay you
to wear it but you got to promise to
wear it everywhere you go
i'm not wearing it everywhere
well then you're not getting the sneaker
get out of here
because we're done
[Applause]